town
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey townies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population you
population cordray Robert W cordray the
third are you a third you guys love
dropping thirds I don't know and it's
not W it's not s what do you call it two
D's when some then they put when they
slap a number at the end of your name I
know what it represents yeah but what is
the official is it is there it's like a
legacy actual yeah you're a family happy
shouted Aaron what is it
it's a suffix just a suffix I don't know
I'm sorry I feel like that I'm gonna go
with Monica Aaron something this is a
town in England anyway
gang here's the deal we learned about it
on Downtown Abbey Downtown Abbey here's
some town we the Downtown Abbey this is
dumb town we we've had you on this show
before Rob and the good news is that the
world continues to get down it gets even
dumber yeah sweet sweet how about that
all right that's the course of evolution
you guys have cornered up really it's a
downward we're like the funeral home uh
of of podcasts because business will
always be good people always gonna be be
dumb and our fans sent us in the stories
J so remember when we like stupid Leaf
lunch thought we're like What if we run
out of story yeah well
and that was
yeah that was stupid on our part all
right so here's the story the new way
that we're doing it robs the last time
is that each of us brings the story you
didn't have to bring one but I've got
one Dan's got one ring I've got one so
here we go Jay ready I'll start with the
headline this was sent in by Derek
Shipley at Derek Shipley uh trigger
warning this is a New York Post article
so it is going to be some shitty puns
terrible puns they'll be bad journalism
yeah you will resent you'll wanna bad
journalism is subjective very true I get
it every time I'm in New York go on okay
your love is like bad journalism bad
journalisms whatever guys we are now on
YouTube we are on all things Comedy
Channel yeah and we are gonna get
flagged every time
that's the most expensive little uh
I said bad journalism
man with 48-year Grudge how long 48-year
Grudge don't worry no no I didn't ruin
it
you need to say sorry to him in a very
specific or maybe you were the angriest
five-year-old
well listen to this man with 48 year
Grudge caught peeing on ex-wife's grave
every day by her kids caught by
fantastic her children
can I can I just also rip on the New
York Post right now yeah because the
writing of that is wrong so caught every
day peeing by her kids so he's peeing
next to her yeah right right right no
caught by her kids as he's peeing on her
graveyard here's the thing too somebody
who does that is constantly telling you
how much they don't care anymore yeah I
don't care and you learn this uh you
know in any sort of like self-evaluation
or even a theater School uh if you're
angry it's because you care that's right
if you didn't care you wouldn't care I
was you're either still in love love and
anger are sometimes she still means love
and fear like fear and anger I thought
of a similar idea related to that I
thought like now this is an act of hate
and yet I can't imagine it's not gleeful
right like this guy must be in the best
mood ever after first of all he's
completely empty so there's that feeling
of relief you're empty of whatever was
inside there but it then if it's going
on for 48 years there's something like I
gotta do this then I gotta go to the
grocery store
when am I going to find time to does it
lose meaning you mean if I don't drink
enough by 11 I'm not gonna have enough P
by one
I can't get over to this side of town
also as a person who used to be a
Gravedigger did you have if you are
peeing every day go ahead on someone's
grave we're listening he
the just even groundskeeping management
of that cemetery is very bad at their
job you should see that there's a guy
48 years I mean all right that's how
long the grudges I don't know how long
it took her it took her children yeah
standing by yeah I don't know that she's
been doing it for he's been doing all
right I've been doing it for 40 years
trying to be funny whatever happened to
letting someone rest in peace I love it
rested that can't believe they didn't
say rest in peace that's what I love
about the the post yes
they're always like writing this article
I'm also a Mucinex commercial
you're in for a great stuff yeah right
hey whip it out you gotta figure it out
and then I laughed at that I
legitimately laughed that's fun a man a
man Fifth and apparent 48-year Grudge
has been going each morning to urinate
on the grave of his ex much to the
horror of her furious kids who realized
something was wrong when they discovered
bags of poop left at their moms what
this guy's now doing you're burying the
lead like he's not sending his poop to
me bad journalism
Freddie pre-bagged it he pre-bagged it I
felt like getting out and killing him
said Michael Andrew Murphy so this is
their former stepdad yeah oh yeah yeah
how old is Michael Andrew Murphy do you
guys think
he felt like killing him felt like him
he's killing
himself
I'm gonna say this guy's 41 years old 41
years old I like that that's I'm gonna
take the over under did you under pick a
number 30
even 30 6 36 29. she's like an angry get
your answers in yell at your YouTube uh
because Michael Andrew Murphy is 43
years old
he told me I figured this guy 48 years
ago this guy's around 68 he came into
the kid's life a little bit later maybe
toriello all right Linda toriela was his
mom all right told the post this guy
Michael told the post what it was like
to catch the man he says he's been
desecrating the barrel side of his mom
at least his mom made an impact on
torielo died in 2017. how old was she
when she died when she died
um the kid was 43 years ago the kid's
43. how and she's been dead how long
since 2017. so six years now on this
yeah yeah she's in her mid 70s right she
was in her mid 70s
am I 74 or 75. oh come on guys come on
you got to pick a number here we're
going this isn't the podcast it is
guessing agent oh yes it is 74. okay
Daniel what do you think I'm gonna go
67 years old when she's 69.7 69. nice
shout at it she was 66 when she died
I don't know I've got anger yeah she was
buried doing the equation
she was buried just over the state line
at a cemetery at tapping this is a
petrol case
he carried poop across state lines
Murphy said his sister first noticed a
plastic bag of poop at their mother's
grave in April I thought it was
something left by mistake by a dog
walker
I'm gonna walk the dog near there's a
lot of people who go through walk
cemeteries they walk their dog through
something walk the dog through the
cemetery and then right on a grave I'm
gonna hate on this but I'm saying not
appropriate but guilty right not
appropriate but not a horrible rationale
when you don't want to believe you don't
want to believe that someone can be that
ridiculous yes I'm gonna do the hard
work of remembering to bring a bag I'm
gonna scoop it up and then I won't throw
it it is weird that it probably isn't it
like an HEB bag like it is weird that
it's changed oh this is dog poo isn't it
I pictured him in his house no no
she's assuming
okay so I'm right yes who went into it
smart people he is lying lined the bag
lined the toilet probably with a bag
this is how you do it
but then of course you have to drive
with it across the state line you have
to drive that where do you put it in
your trunk every day hey Sheriff the
feds are here
all right that's great whatever happened
to letting people
all right it's good then it happened
again the siblings called the cops who
took a report determined to figure out
what was going on at what point do you
put a camera on The Headstone and you're
like we're gonna get a zip yeah got
permission from the cemetery manager to
place trail cameras in the trees in the
trees to see if they could catch the
Vandal I mean on some level they had to
know the anger of this at of the ex
right so curious that's it they don't
say what she did oh yeah I think we got
more oh no when they checked the camera
I don't know what she'd do to them they
spotted the the gross grave visitor
grossful can we make it more
alliteration horrible WWF Stars
a man who briefly buried him for the
Undertaker Mary yellow in the 1970s this
wasn't a guy
in the 70s he was a brief like in people
48 years ago all right I mean 40.
like you see movies from New York in the
70s and there's just trash everywhere
like I feel like people let a lot of
stuff go in the stuff it was a dirty
time
for Mad Men when they get done with the
picnic and they just shake out the book
that's funny because when I was a little
kid the first time I drove through I was
like a toddler when I drove through New
York City my parents just did a detour
and From This Moment On I was fascinated
by it but but halfway down through
Manhattan my dad went what do you think
Bobby and I went dirty
and it was like so dirty you were
talking like early 80s like that's dirty
it was very very dirty over there uh so
Murphy said the video and pictures and
sister oh let me pop up the footage was
blurry and grainy uh to take The
Authority so a week ago it was too
blurry and girl the way the poop also
grainy and it has to do with it so the
footage the trail cameras weren't good
enough so Murphy and his sister got up
at 5am to drive to the cemetery and laid
in wait that's fun playing on a Stakeout
that's a Stakeout it's a poop set up his
smartphone on a nearby headstone which
is a little disrespectful for the other
yeah I put it on herb shallow it says it
wouldn't be great if that gravestone
belonged to a pi and he's he's sort of
helping out with one last year
he's doing work from Beyond which by the
way that could be a show if there's such
a thing as the Long Island Medium
graveyard Pi Dave yeah
dude that could be a show dead guy
I mean there already is a ghost show on
CBS right let's consult I know let's
consult with them I'm literally too old
for this [ __ ] that's just like that is
his
thing is I'm literally too dead for this
[ __ ] yeah on the grave and it's
literally yeah
that's the title of this episode too
dead for this [ __ ]
yeah
and then it cuts the guys [ __ ] all
right uh Murphy said the video and
pictures that he and his sister got
indicated that the man drove to the
cemetery almost every every morning
between what time and what time he's
regular so they're there at five they're
there at five what time 6 a.m I'm gonna
say 6 15. I'm starting the day right
yeah with this I think you're probably
about right yeah I would say but between
six and seven between six and seven
seven to seven thirty I say six he knows
it's 6 15 to 6 30. I mean that's what I
do he's got a little between 6 14 and 6
18 A.M right every day every damn day
this is could also this is retirement
damn he gets up with the exactly
I get up at 5 30. this is the thing
that's keeping him alive this next
detail we will be able to talk about I
think we could talk about it for five to
seven hours okay ready for this yeah
between 6 14 and six LeBron every day
who's better uh with his current wife oh
my god wow so does this woman love him
or fear him right and and in that moment
where she's like he wakes her up in the
way she can't get a dark turn come on
we're going get up you're driving we're
going to drive when I have to go you
know that I need it I need to keep my
vowels I love this does she resent this
oh no no no no no no no this this
grudge-filled man yeah who has uh who
lost his mind in the 70s is now forcing
his wife oh yeah he's not because you
hope they're peas in a pod or or she's
like or she's or he's like honey I'm
going to sleep and she's like nope let's
get her and get her can't it has not
some kind of warning to her like you
know hey everyone what you're like you
know what you're I I'll outlive you and
then I've still got more pee in the
world there's more there's more with
this okay exactly I got time for two
graves I'm retired this is the thing you
see it in horrific ways with like
murders and stuff like that but just in
any odd crazy uh outlier thing it's just
whenever a weird pop finds a weird lid
like because in my mind they are peas in
a Charming way yeah that's our grandma
used to say every pot has a list yes and
then like the fact that his [ __ ] pop
found her like a little butt lid wait
wait wait wait wait by the way if you're
someone who is single and you're like
hearing this you're like God damn it how
can this guy find it somebody will go no
this was not the first date she was he
was like hey we really started to get
along
this is your current wife oh no I'm so
sorry did I say you said my wife's grave
would startled me for a second I thought
either way makes happening
is it your [ __ ] yes yes good question
very good I just felt fear a little bit
more and you drive it there okay I drive
a seat so okay so on some level quite I
bet she's like God he still has feelings
for her yes yeah this guy really gets
invested I mean if the new wife should
be the new wife should be jealous yeah
unless she also hates her this much too
I'm saying she's like he wakes up in the
morning and said I'm too tired
what can I say man there's a thing we do
in society that is good for us right
it's the presumed innocence of the
victim yeah so if you find like oh a
body was found or whatever you're like
oh my God then the new picture you know
if it was a small child you picture your
own son or you're not okay uh if it's a
woman you go it could have been my wife
could have been my sister whatever it is
that's good that we do that in society
we're saying what if this woman deserves
there are some people whose body will be
found that if you knew why it was there
you would go good on you this is Justice
look I heard her kids love her so that
makes me feel like maybe she's not a
horrible but there is a world in which
she's earned this and I'm not saying
that that's the case but some people do
live their lives in a way that they
should be [ __ ] on for all of us and
there's another one there's another
world in which this was the thing that
they did together
and this is the thing she liked more
than anything
he's literally continuing in death what
he did for her wouldn't that be great if
he has to tell the kids that you don't
understand
I promised her how many times do I have
to tell you we were friends at
Thanksgiving Jesus
in New York our best friend was Rick
James ask Bobby he said it's dirty it's
dirty and we told each other we made a
bond and even if we can't cohabitate our
King can live on that was our thing she
died before she told you right she
didn't get to she likes it just listen
to what the son says I can't get my wife
to go out to dinner but this guy gets
his life to go along with him to
desecrate
that is a real thing the sun's now
complaining about his own marriage
that's why his wife hears him giving
this quote she's like hey what the [ __ ]
three shots
way to make this
whoa whoa Rick
hey why don't we take five way to take
this scenario where there's a guy
holding a 48-year grudge peeing on a
grave and bringing human instrument to a
grave is about your wife not going to
Golden Corral I can't get my wife to
recognize I've worn a new shirt that she
doesn't appreciate for three weeks
the sister's just like shut up
so Murphy claims he's gone to the cops
at least three times and they refuse to
let him speak to a detective what what
what is happening that's one of the
problems with the comps Dead Guy P.I get
on it right this is what they should be
doing refund the police
Social Service get him get him a woman
who answered the phone at the orange
Town police station so we don't even
know if she works there now the
article's just like some woman answering
the phone phone ringing you're at the
orange Town Police Station
a woman who turned off a vacuum cleaner
this woman yeah she answers the phone I
can't get my wife
she just works there like her and her
husband have a small business where they
clean public offices yeah and she's like
I'll pick it up
a woman who answered the phone the
orange Town Police Station Saturday
referred to a call referred a call from
the post to the police captain who she
said is not on on weekends that's their
response so we don't do weekends so we
can't deal with you know how crime
usually happens between Monday Friday
remember this is the same town where
somebody dumped [ __ ] and or pissed on a
grave every day for seemingly four years
and no one noticed her care good luck
getting it so I don't know this is what
he said the quote I don't know if the
man owns a dog or is [ __ ] in the bag
himself or is getting some dog [ __ ] wait
Murphy said all I know is that he's
using my mother's grave as a toilet
every morning the man who's named the
post is not revealing since he's not
been charged did not respond to a call
from the post oh my God everyone's
protecting this guy everybody everyone
is you get a lot of protection the pissy
man
good job Murphy's mother listen to this
left Murphy's mother when she was
pregnant and never had anything to do
with his biological daughter the son
claims except for one time earlier this
year
it wasn't their step dad this is their
dad when he ran into the daughter and
said he wished she were dead and cursed
her and the mother so this sounds like a
good guy yeah I mean like there's a guy
who deserves to be protected listen
let's not protect his let's protect his
name he could have been peeing out there
for five years and we wouldn't have
known it Murphy said we only found out
because of the feces because he up to
his game you know why he got greedy got
greedy could have just gotten away with
peeing on the grave with children this
doesn't have a resolution but to me I
think in this scenario if the cops
aren't listening and if these things
aren't happening you are allowed to hide
in the bushes with a baseball bat and
get the [ __ ] out of him or as he's
peeing knock him right in the old you
know
every morning when he goes out to that
car with his wife to drive out to my
mom's gonna have a bat nice space he's
gonna be a nice pile of [ __ ] right on
his car
now you're gonna get now you're breaking
in but I'm just saying I'm right on the
hood of the car right on the hood of the
car
[ __ ] right just throw [ __ ] right into
the radiator okay I'd break his knees
both kneecaps and then we can't go to
the cemetery and then run and then we're
gonna say I don't want you guys to get
threatened me he threatened me he
threatened me he threatened me he
threatened me by trying to be on me I
was coming back from a baseball game and
uh at the walking through the center as
I was swinging through the center known
to happen to see and I was not paying
attention and he walked right his knee
it was an accident I ran into a lot of
family members at the cemetery I hit him
right there all right Story number one
down in the books how do you like this
you guys if you're watching this on
YouTube we're so happy if you're
listening to it yeah subscribe like And
subscribe tell people about this if
you're listening on the regular feed
like you normally do uh go watch some of
this this is so great this is going to
be at the all things comedy on their uh
YouTube page and there'll be a playlist
for our stuff we are so happy to be here
at all things comedy and we got another
story Dan I believe your story number
two we'll find out what Rob's doing and
what we're doing Story number two on The
Other Side
Story number one was Story number two
there you go and we'll be right back
with more done people town right after
this
hey guys welcome back to dumb people
town uh this is coming out in January uh
we're not sure exactly which week but if
it's before the 18th round it's going to
be one of the first two weeks so it's
either the 10th or the 8th of the 17th
so this weekend will be in Denver at
Comedy Works doing shows uh on the 18th
through the 20th and uh very excited to
do those at the Landmark Club one of our
favorite clubs in the world to perform
Denver's such a great City we want to
see everybody out there at the end of
the month uh beginning of February we'll
be in San Diego at the American Comedy
Company the second to the fourth and
then the fifth live dumb people Town
what a full weekend isn't that great in
San Francisco as part of sketchfest
Sunday night it's the last show schedule
home every year yeah 20 years the
anniversary we've been there since the
beginning yeah you're doing it too we're
closing it out I believe so in in a
sense you guys are opening for us we are
opening you before we're right before
you guys on that Sunday night Sunday
I love it there you go oh yeah so that's
that and then for me guys every
Wednesday at the lyric Hyperion theater
it's the lyric Comedy Hour it's Irene
two and myself hosting just a great
local uh La comedy show I love it and
then I will be doing stand-up the night
before uh our dumb people Town that's
the 4th of February at sketchfest so
come out and see my show there and then
stick around for Sunday let's all hang
together yeah yeah it'll be a real good
time everything else is up at
danielvankirk.com cordri where can
people see you like what are you working
on well in the Los Angeles area I live
uh around like the reservoir if you're
walking I sometimes walk around the
reservoir you can see me
um dig into Old pretty much in my house
yeah okay I have just went with this
terrible terrible idea because I have
nothing to show for myself no no no I'm
joking yeah no I have not no what do I
got I have a movie coming out soon oh
it's very scar related I wish I knew the
date I think it's in January and yeah
why don't you hey look it up this would
be fun 80 for Brady for break that true
story
2016 Super Bowl I believe yeah so it's
Lily Tomlin Lily Tomlin Rita Moreno Rita
Moreno who by the way someone said I
thought they fell in love with Rita
Miranda fell in love with Julian Edelman
was like I think I think I'm in love
with I think I'm in love with Rita
Moreno
I mean you've heard you're falling in
love with Julian I don't know there you
go
uh no we've heard a lot about this movie
and it's going to be super and right Rob
corgi's in it it's funny all right shall
we get into a second let's do it let's
do it number two here we go I mean real
number two
Raleigh company sent in by who oh okay
I'll do it don't you don't I dare you
Randy Raleigh but but never will Raleigh
company wants to invade your home what
oh wait this was sent in by the Shipley
at Derek Shipley ready for this I hope I
hope yeah okay a report claimed a
rally-based exterminator will pay a
family for the chance to release how
many cockroaches no into their home no
and we're gonna get into this and you're
going to learn all the details but I
wanted to start out with that here's all
you need to know there is a company in
Raleigh who says hey we want to release
we want to release cockroaches into your
home and then we'll kill them
deliberately I believe they are an
exterminator well I guess we're going to
find how many cockroaches do you think
they want to put into your home on
purpose how many is a lot of cockroaches
one one is alive if you're an
exterminator how much is a lot of how
many is a lot I think ten thousand then
releases
you're gonna go last Jason I I think
it's 500 500. that feels like a lot to
me yeah I'd say a thousand a thousand
okay
they would like to release 100
cockroaches one into your home now
here's the thing that's still a lot it's
here Lenny cockroaches if I'm not I said
ten thousand turn around on these is
like a week right where they die and
then no no I'm saying more they're like
[ __ ] Mob Wives yes dude yeah they
start [ __ ] oh they have a baby in a
day yes I think that's right
it can easily become a thousand can
easily become ten thousand you better
get in there and solve this in a day
yeah who would do this what a challenge
WRAL
okay first of all time out for this we
had someone and I'm gonna let you guys
decide because I know what I would like
to do we had someone so beautifully and
innocently DM me and say what does that
mean when they said every time you guys
recall letters you do this weird
inflection thing and I've gone back
through so many episodes to find the
origin of it and I don't notice now
there's a part of me that wants to never
answer this yeah you got to dude
yeah that's what I was
100 what it is
or do you just want to say where to go
to find out say go watch the movie
private parts and then come back okay
okay
um WRAL news
we're such a great scene that movie's
way better than it ever
yeah
I have been listening to so much Howard
Stern in my car yeah and I'm same he is
so joyfully I was like well if he starts
this is when he went on seriously I'm
like it starts cursing part of the
beauty was how he would tiptoe up to the
line cross it in certain ways and I'm
like what's is it he is so great in the
ways that like Ronnie the Limo Driver
will do like the most just the winding
the most whining yeah he's complaining
he gets into fights with everybody and
Howard should be like shut the [ __ ] up
you know
he'll start saying then Robin jumps on
his okay hold on
just we'll go back I promise we're gonna
go back but I will say for anybody who
doesn't listen to stern or doesn't like
whatever it is it's just a simple thing
you've all experienced in this your life
God forbid you are this person it's one
of those things when someone's being
wound up and they don't realize all they
need to do is go towards it yeah to make
it stop like when they're like I don't
know I think you got a problem with
wearing hoodies and you oh yeah I
definitely have a problem I wear it all
the time yeah but the person who goes I
don't have a problem it's like the turn
and you just want to put your hand on
their shoulder and be like technology
go in go towards it and just agree with
it nope they will not agree in here and
Gary's so dumb get Gary in here we go
I've been laughing so much me too it's
just killing right let's do this all
right have you done the show have you
guessed it I have it was it was I it was
it's cringe-worthy really I got into a
long fight with Benji bronc who at the
time was in the studio and
um what's this guy talking about and
then and then on the wrap-up show later
the whole wrap-up show was Benji and I
fighting to the point where I saw red oh
my God almost Dove over no way oh my God
like it was probably made for the
greatest radio ever uh it made Howard
uncomfortable get it from what I was
told like that episode was buried for
the long time I heard he got a talking
to and I never felt good about it and
I've never been asked back there you go
but the great thing is the context of
that show that could be entirely a
reason for you to come back oh my god
well I would apologize to him yeah
honestly if I uh because I don't like
attacking him no no but it all came out
of the celebrity uh superfan Roundtable
where they said Somebody's Natalie main
said who's your least favorite Stern
Show person personality and ice and uh I
was fourth in line sure yeah I was like
well it's I guess it's Benji if I had to
say and then there was like Johnny
Knoxville Benji yeah uh somebody else
Andy Richter Benji they each had smarter
reasons why and then it got to me and I
was like I don't know I guess it's Benji
and then I had to think up of batteries
and I said because we all we're all in
the entertainment business who would
hire him as a writer oh God after the
show which is a terrible thing to say
about it he actually called up in that
show I've had three fights with him oh
my God I apologize Benji Bronk sorry but
I do sorry about that and then if you're
watching deserve that you didn't deserve
it see he's a good man I like you own it
out all right all right okay ready
releasing a hundred cockroaches this
news station yeah WRAL uh they worked to
confirm this information including
calling a phone number provided reaching
out via email and ringing the bell at an
address listed but was unable to contact
the company about this offer so this is
not a real company they're just people
who want to really it is but I think
that they have faced a lot of backlash
over this so they're not they're trying
to just right they're pretending we're
going to say who they are anyway the
pestinformer.com is taking applications
for up to seven homes to participate in
a cockroach elimination study which the
company said will be safe for family
members and pets you all have homes
what world none zero you go with
families and pets no bring any road
you've dealt with rodents in your house
so I can tell you in terms of not being
able to reach this company they we were
we had a problem with our garage door
and Terminix tried to like put this
thing on the bottom that would you know
basically seal it up so the rest can't
get it on the bottom and they broke our
garage door so our garage door wasn't
working so now I had to like call this
guy to be like look you I I'm not paying
for a new garage and I'm calling and
calling calling this guy doesn't call me
back and then finally I called somebody
else and they're like he left the
company I'm like no one told me he
didn't tell me so now I'm down this
other Road and I got these other things
I'm like there's no you can't that's how
they screw you by the way they are like
the the companies themselves are like
rodents you try and find them you see
you got to lay a trap on them to come
out and then you can just turn the
lights on they run according to the
company website the pest Informer was
founded in 1994 with the goal of keeping
Pest Control safe for humans and animals
okay the purpose of this study is to
determine how effective a new
extermination treatment is so they don't
even know
can you do this on like a test house
ready for this how about a house where
people are squatting okay remember they
want to put a hundred cockroaches into
your house quickly gonna turn into a
thousand we take them 100. it might work
what we're doing might work put them in
a house and find out what happens when
they how much money how much money would
you let that we're gonna get to that but
first i'm gonna ask you how many days do
you think that you have to live with the
Cockroaches while they see if the new
treatment works you live with them oh
they're putting them in your house and
they say that they're good they have X
amount of days that they want you to
live with the Cockroaches while they try
out this this is a mature movie this is
somebody's going to sign up this is the
plot of the Ring I don't watch movies I
would say how many days do you think
they want you to have cockroaches they
want you while they try out they want
you to do it for seven goddamn Days
Seven Days yeah
I'll I'll say two weeks okay 14 days
okay I'll say Benji sucks
like a business week right the
pestinformer.com
wants you to have 100 cockroaches in
your house in your house while they try
out an experimental new treatment for
coffee we don't know if it works and you
need to have these cockroaches in your
house four
30 days
no it's a month a month 30 days that's
more than a month 30 days at the end of
the 30-day period if the new treatment
didn't work the Cockroach infestation
will be eliminated using traditional
methods the the hold they would have on
your house in 30 days oh my God what are
they testing it will be used with
traditional Methods at no cost to the
household accordingly okay all right
give it a shot what do you get what's
the what's the um
applicants must be 21 or older and own
their own home or have written approval
from the owner imagine going to your
landlord with that hey
[Laughter]
is this weird if selected households
will not be permitted to use other
exterminator Services during the study
so if you get 16 days in and there's
like nothing changing you don't get to
call somebody else and there's just like
get in here cockroaches all over
everything and you know the whole time
they're like give it give us the 30 days
30. trust us 20 days
sleep at night no we're trying to see if
it works we're going to get out of here
on this okay how much how much money are
they offering you to have 100
cockroaches put into your house
no I know I will tell you what the
answer you want to go first or go first
ready yeah not enough
you gotta know what is it actually there
is a number there is a number 10 million
dollars I'm saying for you to do it
there is a number there are other
numbers no no no zero I it wouldn't
marry you guys know my wife it's not
even new house money if it was new I
would not we it because you have to live
in it just I I would be I would do it I
would build here's what I would do I
have a number I would that is funny what
is the number you would do it for I
would do it for 10. I would do it for 10
million dollars I would tell them I'm
staying at my house I would sleep
elsewhere so you're telling me I had
three million dollars cash to slide
across activities you'd say no you're
breaking a contract well but the point
is not to like the point is can we
release them and can we kill them in
human ways it's not about you living
with them it's more about cancer does
this thing work right my question is why
can't they just do that in an abandoned
house no because they want to see if it
affects pets or kids by the way they're
like they may kill your dog they may
kill your dog straight to human testing
we have to see if this works with vets
and dogs I think it had 10 million as
well so I'm gonna say they're offering
like twenty thousand dollars twenty
thousand dollars which I think is way
high for them yeah Rob do you want 1
million is way too low I agree because
I'm nuts okay um but um but you have a
do you have a guess I said do it for
five million dollars and then I would uh
what are they offering they're offering
twenty five hundred dollars they that's
all they care about and they're like
we're gonna get people because if you
offer too much like the people that you
gather into off too much are going to
ask too many questions and they're gonna
but if you offer a certain amount where
people are like someone's like I can't
pay for the salary have cockroaches in
my house I need 2 500 I'll do it then
you go you load a thousands yeah Randy
you you're using you're using far too
much logic here I think you guys have
offered zero
upshot except not even barely for them
rarely and and I so I'm gonna go really
low and say 250 dollars and I would do
it for how much for 100 1.4 billion
billion billion that's a b 1.4 there's a
b at the beginning oh my God oh my God
uh if you're watching this on YouTube
first of all God bless you thank you for
joining secondly I want in your comments
the amount you would have to be paid I
I'm curious to hear what you would it's
real too like when I said like I said to
Jay like he said 10 million but if I
slid 3 million cash across the table I
don't think you're walking away from
three million okay it depends on what
kind of bills if it's hundreds it's
gonna look like a smaller thing than
what it is we're gonna do half Krypton
okay and I'm with cordray is a perfectly
reasonable answer which reminded me of
something else you have going on which
I'll say as we get are you ready for the
ready for running this out I think the
money for me
at this point in my life for 30 days
knowing that I've lived with cockroaches
at least twice in my life way longer
than I should have had to don't call
your roommates though
um
I would probably do it for five hundred
thousand dollars which means I would
really probably do it for a hundred
grand okay Dan okay ready how much Dirty
Bird I know I'm not probably New York
City
also when they find out I didn't even
live there for the month all right that
wasn't even there okay shouldn't have
slid that cash across the table Yeah I'd
be hard I mean 100K right in front of
you the amount of money that they are
offering to put 100 cockroaches in your
house with kids and pets for 30 days
yeah
is
two thousand dollars
and I was right and so this you made
sense out of that so time seven they
want to be seven Homes at 2K a past so
fourteen thousand dollars
I'm smart enough that I'm gonna win
anyway does that spark a new podcast
game show thing Amy's gonna win anyway
yeah yeah it's sort of uh we don't have
a date or anything okay but it was
really fun that you guys are doing that
oh it's great it's for smartless
um we're doing uh yeah it's like a it's
a game show but it's more of just like a
it's a game show [ __ ] around yeah
um and uh we're just uh we're we're
trying to I'm going to bring my friends
on and see if they can beat Amy
Schneider who's like the 40 time yeah
she's second winningest person oh yeah
she's amazing the most recent Tournament
of Champions Champion yeah she's amazing
and the title is Amy always wins Amy
always wins yeah so good luck yeah yeah
which is also great too because like you
better have fun because Amy's gonna win
I mean he's gonna win yeah that is the
title put your hair about your marriage
right
all right guys all right guys story
that's the cockroach is always the books
uh I've got a different way to ride in a
car okay and I've got that coming up
after the break Rob cordu is with us so
don't go anywhere it's no people town
and we love that you guys are watching
this we'll see you right uh after this
break stick around
don't people
hey guys welcome back you're going to
take us back hey before you jump into
that show I want to remind everybody
that our patreon is only five bucks and
you we do your story so send in personal
dumb stories from your own life and if
you say to yourself I've never done
anything done first of all you're a liar
uh you could send in a dumb story pre
2005 if you really must but we want
personal ones we've already got a couple
um they've probably started dropping as
we're recording Dan I have a wonderful I
have a friend who wants to send in a
story how would he slash I love when you
take us into like infomercial all of a
sudden there's a picture of lemonade
we all have sweaters and I like the
sound of that how would one of my
friends who was asking me about it to
send in and send it just email it right
Dan is it that simple if they act right
now okay they act right now what do they
do uh they would go to I believe and I
love that I've never confirmed but I'm
almost sure it's the dptpodcast
gmail.com and if you want to verify my
information go to the yeah just go to
the patreon
so you just put your story in and then
we will do it and by the way five bucks
and for five bucks so much fun because
we've laughed five bucks a month years
it's awesome with our townspeople and
now we get to laugh at them and we bring
you in them
and here's the deal you get for five
bucks it's uh ad free is that correct
yes also you get that you get the
episodes uh you get dumb people telling
episodes all right you ready for this
you ready for this story yeah the story
sent in by Beth okay thank you Beth I
hear you calling Matt oh wait hold on
time out
I it's been too many weeks what you guys
followed a Kiss cover band oh yeah oh my
god did you see them post about this so
we followed this they post a thing like
oh yeah I love who booked the order of
this which was fun and tongue-in-cheek
you weren't being mean but but yeah this
is great they're the kids you have full
reasons I know but I'm just saying I
didn't know
in the middle of the middle of the show
you would always have them close so
obviously but like I for a second was
like how big is this gig you guys are
doing set the Fillmore yes it was that
the Fillmore so I thought did they get
Gene to come out no Jewish event he is
Israeli he's Australian so is Paul
Stanley but uh okay so it's a kiss
coverage in the middle of the show you
guys are in the balcony and we're in the
balcony and looking down and the best
part is that these are just like we
watch these guys regular dudes like
accountants put on their makeup
sounded like the Gene Simmons guys
so but the Paul Stanley guy is wearing
these giant platforms seven inch heels
and his heel broke off at the ball of
his foot and so the sound guy had to
come on during very spinal tap and tape
it Up Performance playing and then he
took one more step and then fell off
again and he had to do you talked about
it on stage
we're like how Jewish is that of course
this is the Jewish kiss the guy who
won't buy new shoes
and then we did our bit about uh yes the
kid like I want to rock and roll all
night and party every day every day that
sounds like the worst thing I've ever
heard in my head did you see those guys
on stage right now I don't think they
could album we're like yes they're like
I don't think they could have partied
the first day after the first night that
they rocked and rolled up people need to
go listen to hipsters that's a great
hour that's a great bit okay all right
okay Beth at love mzu love MCU and I
think she might be a new contributor I
know thank you Beth yeah uh this video
of this so we'll post this up as we're
doing this and our wonderful uh tactical
man producer engineer Aaron will help us
with this but man man
rode on top of car while SUV drove
through town awesome like so like Teen
Wolf style like Styles maybe maybe we'll
styles are so good I'm I don't you might
have to show us on a phone sandusk Ohio
do you have footage of rad people I
think it's time they changed that name
you can change the name of it'll be in
the Youtube it'll be at the end it'll be
on social media but somewhere you don't
have to I don't need it so man wrote man
accused of outrageous Joy writing he's
accused that's a crime
that's the official charge yeah he's
having too much fun this guy no that'll
get you that'll grow yeah also don't you
want two weeks if you're not in your
early 20s what are you going through Jay
do you remember when we what are you
going our friends sounds fun our friends
Jason court and Brian Steinberg we visit
them in Kansas City when we were in high
school he had the big red this old red
car where the seat belts we brought them
up onto the roof and held on to them on
the roof of the cared we used to do a
thing and we don't have a problem with
that we used to do a thing in Rochelle
where you would tie sleds to the back of
like snow-covered roads and that the
trucks would drive you around while you
sleep I did Dumber things yeah I mean I
mean this is
amateur yeah I mean but Road on top of
the car he's too much all right so
here's the joyride I would just look at
this guy and be like she's not coming
back man yeah
it's not gonna happen yeah well I can
get her I can get her back let me do
this man they're gonna we're gonna put
it in the post I guess unless you think
we need to see it right now he's up
there anyway so
here's what happened okay on top of UV
early Sunday morning on Columbus Avenue
in downtown Senate so he's just going
through downtown
where San Dustin Sandusky Ohio so okay
team obtained dash camera video of the
man so we'll show this okay the officer
pulled the vehicle over and charged both
the driver and the man with a minor
misdemeanor of riding outside the
vehicle I didn't know that was the
misdemeanor when I came to that vehicle
I
well apparently you ready for this
Lieutenant Scott
Dahlgren I'm like you I know that's your
name but you're you you're misspelling
and mispronouncing
dog dog
it's illegal and extremely dangerous
Lieutenant Scott Dahlgren said we're all
grateful he wasn't seriously injured are
you really great come on there's no way
he's going I don't know do you think
he's grateful that they were seriously
injured so we're all grateful that he
was local cop script right on the
officer's body camera video you can
actually see the car come from around a
building that's down there down there
love a good down there where is it well
can you be more specific it came from
down there this is one of those local
news stories that's written for everyone
is already in the know right they don't
have well it's down there he's came from
down there well you know how Saturdays
are here he's down by the trees yeah
over by Fred's yeah over there yeah like
these articles tend to start out with
like it happened again like you know you
already know you know Janet again we
don't know Jeff anyway and then you can
uh see the individual Standing On Top of
the car as he's standing on the roof he
seems to see the officer at that point
he gets down onto his knees and then
goes straight to to a straight prone
position he's doing yoga oh that's smart
yeah on his knees
I couldn't do that he's like a little
kid hiding exactly yeah you're like are
you over there no so this is when I
would like to be driving underneath some
bridges this is yeah just like this is
my favorite haircut this is my favorite
like this is gonna make you guys love
the guy on the car all the morning this
is where this is the point in the
article which I love the guy on the car
so much shortly after the officer pulled
the vehicle over he asked the man if
there was any reason why he was on the
roof the man said no
I don't need a reason to do that right
living
in you don't need no rhyme because it
was there we have not heard if it's some
kind of a tick tock challenge or
Internet challenge said Raleigh some
kind of tick tock challenge blame the
Chinese
sort of dank meme
but obviously it's out there and this is
something people are going to start
trying to do
this maybe if you're saying so by the
way if we were like hey have you heard
about this a lot of people on top of
cars recently like no this is one dumb
guy also people look I guess I already
cited Teen Wolf people have been doing
this forever not nice good chicken this
could get somebody hurt but this fella
is inciting or a long-term right what
was the reason why he was up there no no
reason no speed I was wondering it can't
be that fast it was not fast we put the
video up but it was not that fast but it
to me is just real it's a short story
but it's just really
and to me how funny would it be if
dahlgren's like description of it he
inspires there now to be a thing on Tick
Tock like dahlgren's saying that it was
a thing it's like the he's wagging the
dog on The Tick Tock thing get in here
you idiot you did it again you inspired
you went viral again you mad man
dog you son of a [ __ ] was there any
what if this this would be the rap of
the whole thing Dahlgren was there any
reason you brought up a tick tock
challenge or some internet challenge in
the middle of inter being interviewed
for this story and he's like no no no no
no there was nothing
the third story that's how we do it here
this is the new version
and they were on the set look at the
news sign we got Rob cordray here uh
check out uh everything the new movie
he's gonna be in 80 for Brady and uh you
can check out all of our stuff thank you
for supporting us like some smash that
subscribe button and the like button on
this video and let's just build this
thing up we're so happy to be at all
things comedy and oh [ __ ] we got to get
back to work
stick around
[Music]